welcome back to cinema recapped today
i'll show you and explain a drama
fantasy and romantic series from 2000
called the sound of magic spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
episode 1 the series begins with a group
of girls talking about a rumor of a
magician who lives in an abandoned
amusement park they say he's very
handsome but also crazy and that he
disappears people with his magic then we
meet ahi a somewhat clumsy and shy girl
and il jung a smart and handsome boy
they both go to the same class and are
seat mates one day ie gets a part-time
job and gets paid for her first day
however on the way home the money flies
away she starts following it trying to
catch it until it reaches the abandoned
amusement park there she sees a magician
holding her money and she gets so scared
that she decides to run away back at
home we see that she has a younger
sister and that their parents don't live
with them so they both live alone with
almost nothing to eat and they also
several months of rent the next day a
smug girl annoys aji by leaving her a
bill on the ground humiliate her but
having need of it ai decides to forget
her pride and pick it up that night ai
looks for the magician at the park to
get her money back and when he sees her
he teaches her some simple magic tricks
in the end he returns her money ai buys
food for her little sister and one day
after finishing work she asks her boss
for a loan to pay the rent he gives it
to her but then he tries to take
advantage of her at that moment the
magician arrives and he defends aie by
making the man disappear with a magic
trick ahi is very surprised so the next
day she decides to look for the magician
again to ask what happened to her boss
he replies that he used magic to make
him disappear i.e tells him that she
doesn't believe in that so the magician
decides to show her magic with
butterflies and fireworks episode 2 ayi
wonders if what happened that night was
real then while leaving school she
decides to go to the store of her former
boss and realizes that he has not yet
appeared ahi arrives at her home and
there she meets the magician who
apparently followed her from the park he
does magic tricks for the little sister
and just at that moment some men arrive
demanding payment from them i.e tells
them that she doesn't have money to pay
her father's debt so the men get angry
and start attacking her however the
wizard intervenes and tells ai to order
him what to do with them i.e tells him
that if he's a real magician he should
pay the debt and at that moment the
petition makes a lot of money up here
but the men realize that it's fake so
they end up beating the magician the
next day il
invites ie to study together the library
as he seems to start having feelings for
her because ie is very smart at math
meanwhile the smug girl and her friend
look for the magician in the park when
they find him they demand that he prove
that he does magic so he decides to show
them some tricks and almost stabs the
smug girl through magic but still she
doesn't believe him then just before he
leaves the magician tells the smug girl
to tell ie that he is waiting for her
the next day the smug girl starts
telling the school that hai and the
magician are lovers and this is heard by
ildung ah ye hears these rumors and goes
to complain to the magician for causing
problems he replies that he likes her
and we see that del young hears this
because he followed aye to the park
ilding decides to leave and ai tells the
magician not to joke about that then the
magician shows her a new trick in which
he makes ai's mom who apparently
abandoned her when she was little read
all the messages ie has sent her since
she left the next day i.e goes to school
and meets hildyung who offers her a lot
of money in exchange for her answering
badly on the math test so that he can be
the best student since apparently ie
beats him in each exam episode three ai
thinks about whether to accept or not
and when she gets home she realizes that
her little sister needs money to go on a
school trip i.e accepts ill dung's
proposal and on the day of the exam she
writes some answers wrong that night ai
visits the magicians and she feels sad
about her grades and the magician tries
to cheer her up by putting her on one of
the mechanical games and then he
proposes to teach her how to do magic
tricks but how you reply is that maybe
another day would be better a few days
later they hand out the grades revealing
that il diung was the highest in the
class at dismissal time ilding pays ayu
what they agreed and also proposes to
continue giving her money in exchange
for his homework i.e agrees and spends
several days doing his homework in
exchange for money then one day ahi
visits the magician to learn magic
tricks and we see the dildo jung follows
her and that he's watching them from
afar when aye leaves ilding goes to talk
to the magician to warn him not to hurt
the girl and the magician does some
magic causing ildium to imagine things
and when he returns to reality he's so
scared that he decides to get out of
there quickly the next day el diong
talks to ayii it demands that she not
see the magician again however ai does
not obey him that afternoon she goes
again when she arrives she realizes that
a pregnant woman is with him and she
begins to think that he has a wife
another day aiu returns to visit the
edition and together they practice magic
when suddenly il doing appears and says
that he's also interested in learning
the magician shows them both various
tricks and at first ill doing is jealous
of the magician but then he also gets
carried away with a show and even ends
up trying to do magic himself the next
day ie is called to the principal's
office and one of her teachers asked for
explanations since a photo has been
leaked in which il diung is seen giving
her money and he thinks she's extorting
him episode four i.e doesn't answer in
any way so the teacher asks her to bring
her dad tomorrow ali decides to go to
the park and sends a letter to her dad
who also abandoned her she puts the
letter in a forgotten mailbox since the
magician told her that that mailbox is
magical and that it sends letters
anywhere later we see that the smug girl
and her friend break into the magician's
house in the park and manage to hide a
camera without the magician noticing
that night ie arrives home and realizes
that her father has returned so she's
happy she then asked him to show up at
her school the next day before going to
sleep i put some money that she was
going to use for household expenses in
her backpack since she wants to return
it till djing the next day to fix the
problem however the next day she
realizes her dad ran off with the money
attends school and has no choice but to
tell the teacher the truth about the
deal with illume another day aye goes to
school and sees il diung being given an
award for being generous
since the teacher apparently made up a
story about ill do you and giving ie
charity money and everyone starts
telling her that she only lives on
handouts ai goes to the magician and
tells him how fed up she is with adults
while ill dejung has an argument with
his mother since she discovered that ill
dieung is learning magic she threw all
his magic materials away claiming it's a
waste of time the smug girl retrieves
her camera and while reviewing the
footage at home realizes that she
recorded something shocking the next day
aye goes to her school and before
entering she is stopped by police
officer who asked her if she's seen a
man who is very similar to the tradition
since he is suspected of having
something to do with the disappearance
of a girl ali replies no
the smug girl shows aye a dildoon the
memory card with the video recorded by
the camera ali and ill doing decide to
watch it after school and they see the
magician beating a man episode 5 ie and
illung leave the room and the snooty
girl tells them to report the video to
the police however hillary jung warns
her that if she does so she will
probably get in trouble too for putting
the camera out without permission later
ie goes to see the magician to ask him
about what was seen in the video but she
finds him playing with some children so
she decides to go when she leaves she
sees the pregnant woman who asks her to
exchange contact information in case
something happens that night the smug
girl goes to the petition's house on the
sly to take evidence of what happened in
the video but just at that moment she's
caught by the magician the smug girl
tells the petition that he's crazy and
that he's a scammer so an argument
begins and the girl ends up knocking the
magician's pet down causing it to be
very injured the magician gets very
angry so he tries to suffocate the girl
but she ends up escaping ile de jung has
another argument with his parents
because they demand that he work harder
at his studies they wanted to be a
prosecutor but he just wants to be happy
doing magic that night illung decides to
go see the magician but he falls asleep
in the park and only sees how he has
covered him with his cape that same
night we see how a man similar to the
musician assaults an old lady the next
day the police go to talk to ayii at
school about the magician since they
believe he is the one behind the old
lady's crime at that moment ie's former
boss also appears and tells the police
that the magician threw him down a
ravine the night he disappeared aye
tries to explain to them that the
magician is a good person and just at
that moment hildiung walks in and tells
him that he was with the magician the
night before so he can assure them that
he was not the one who assaulted the old
lady later ildehyung's parents arrived
and talked to him demanding that he not
testify in favor of the magician because
that would stain his reputation causing
ill deon to get so frustrated that he
breaks the window then we see that
someone is running when suddenly he sees
a body floating in the middle of a leg
episode six the police arrive to check
the body in the lake and realize that it
is the girl who was missing and at the
same time they find a knife near the
crime scene that has the magician's
fingerprints on it later ai goes to look
for the magician and finds him hidden in
his house taking care of his pet which
has a little life left ali warns him
that the police are looking for him and
the magician replies that he did nothing
at that moment the police arrive and
arrest the magician but before leaving
he entrusts his pet to ai then aye tells
illyung what happened and they both
decide to contact the pregnant woman the
woman tells them that she knew the
magician since high school at that time
he was one of the most intelligent
students and part of a famous family but
that one day fed up with so much study
he decided to throw himself off a
building and ended up in the hospital
she explains to them that after that he
ended up going to a psychiatric hospital
and that she didn't know anything about
him until 10 years later she also says
that even though he's changed he doesn't
think he's capable of hurting someone
meanwhile we see that the police
interrogate the magician but they can't
get anything out of him so they decide
to review the evidence again and when
they look back they realize that the
magician has vanished ali finds out that
the magician escaped so she decides to
look for him in the park when she
arrives she runs into the policemen who
are trying to convince the magician to
return of his own free will ayy asks the
officers to give her a moment alone with
the magician she tells him that she
believes that he's not guilty and that
she also believes that he's a real
magician since thanks to him
she believes in magic again the magician
is happy to hear that and before going
to the police he decides to give his hat
to aji so that now she can do magic when
she receives it ai decides to say some
magic words and using a blanket makes
the magician disappear a few days later
the magician's pet dies so ie and her
little sister bury him later we see that
the police discover that the real
culprit of both crimes is actually ai's
former boss and that he tried to frame
the magician he was also responsible for
the video recorded by the camera of the
smug girl since he provoked the magician
that night ildiung decides to drop out
of high school to live a quieter life
and find himself some time later we see
ie as a college student who from time to
time visits the magician's house to
remember him and in the afternoons she
does magic for the children
the end
make sure to subscribe and turn on
notifications so you can watch more
videos like this thanks for watching